from the San Francisco Chronicle what we
know about David de Pape man accused of
attacking Paul Pelosi with a hammer
first and foremost the story is he broke
into the house I believe it was in the
wee hours of the morning screaming
where's Nancy it's what they've reported
and then mercilessly beat Paul Pelosi
with a hammer I mean it's deranged and
unhinged but many people are trying to
figure out what the motivations of this
man was of course immediately people on
the right were saying sounds like crime
it's San Francisco why would we assume
otherwise I think that's logical many on
the left said clearly it's Republicans
it's Maga this is what they want for you
well they were wrong it turns out he
listed himself as a member of the green
party voting records show de Pape listed
himself as a member of the green party
years ago so this is not somebody who
just had on his profile it's not it's
not the media just claiming it it's
actually in his records green party yo
green party is leftist now it's not like
antifa it's not like Democrats or
anything it's like its own you know sect
of leftists but that's what it is it was
an unhinged leftist conspiracy theorist
when I when I when I talk to people on
the left and I say that the left has
their share of conspiracy weirdos they
always tell me that's not true and then
you point out the weird hippie crystals
Natural Health anti-government anti-war
stuff and they say oh but that's not
really left wing and I'm just like shut
up dude bro the guy was a leftist I'm
not saying that's why he did it he was
an anti-government conspiracy theorist
this doesn't have to be about politics
it can be about a crazy guy but being
for Natural Health isn't a conspiracy
theory but but anyway
I'm not saying this way I'm saying there
are conspiracy theorists who have like a
conspiracy view of natural stuff it's
kind of sad how you know something
tragic happened something really bad
happened someone gets seriously hurt and
the first thing that happens is everyone
jumps online trying to blame it on some
other political opponent for their own
political purposes uh I think it's fair
to say this guy was crazy he was
unhinged he was absolutely a lunatic and
it's horrible it sucks what happened
here and of course it should be always
said that that this should never happen
and not out of place in San Francisco
which has a massive Mental Health Health
crisis you have people like this this
green party guy all over the street so I
mean it goes without saying that it's
probably just a matter of the crime the
homelessness I think he had a house he
lived with roommates or something yeah
dude had a pride there's a pride flag an
American flag pride flag in front of the
house apparently well he was it he was
living specifically he's a part of a
nudist organization in group two Public
Safety investigative reporter for NBC
bay area posted this image of this house
and there's a pride flag that is not a
right-wing dude now look I I agree with
you Luke and I also I think there's an
inherent problem with how we try to
fairly represent this if this was a uh
when when it was only known that he
posted election conspiracy theories they
were all like saying oh it's Maga it's
Trump supporters this proves that they
immediately latched on and went for the
political attack then we find out it's a
green party guy with a pride flag and we
go guys guys calm down we shouldn't make
this political right
that's that that's a huge problem I'm
not saying I know a solution I say we
should ban nudists and and put them into
camps clearly the nudists are surely
responsible for all of this and they
were working for this all along
especially with their secret society and
organization that they have set up in
San Francisco where they have been
clearly popping up out of nowhere
randomly all the time but I'm telling
you what if I'm just I'm just a match I
want you to bear with me and I want you
to imagine a perfect world for a moment
tomorrow Nancy Pelosi holds a press
conference and she says
what happened to my husband if he had a
Magnum 357 this wouldn't have happened I
am now in favor of the second amendment
that was my second thought the first
thought was well how injured was he
hopefully he's okay kind of thing and
then the brain surgery did he have a gun
he didn't fire on this this home
Intruder we could have gone in San
Francisco bro yeah so like if he had had
a gun and the guy broke in with a hammer
to crack his skull he probably would
have fired on the guy put him down and
then ended the invasion in in that that
again is a radical idea that makes no
sense at all clearly what we have to do
here is Ban hammers hammers are the
problem there's too many of them anyone
could just get them without any
background checks anyone could just
transfer a hammer to another person
clearly right now the government has to
intervene go to Home Depot immediately
shut down the Hammers no no no no no one
is actually saying band hammers we just
want Common Sense Hammer control okay
yes no military very great hammer
handles we don't want any scary Hammer
uh heads no black hammers no black
hammers at all no it needs to happen no
bump stock no bump stock Hammer right
can somebody it's time to start making
to meet the memes whatever
it's time to start making the memes we
need to start making memes of bump stock
hammers pistol grip hammers pump action
hammers just have added friends
no no but Hammer foregrip but you
brought up a great Point Ian absolutely
people should be armed especially if
they're elderly especially if they're
living in a crime-ridden place like San
Francisco especially if they're popular
and everyone knows where they live this
is not the first time that the Pelosi's
have had their house targeted everyone
should have the right to defend
themselves and whether you're a woman or
someone who's elderly or someone who's
who's weak or fragile whatever it may be
what is the great equalizer is you
having the ability to be able to defend
yourself in a firearm does that more and
better than anything else out there I
also want to know what uh what
prescriptions he was on what pills
because this is really what it comes
down to It's A Mental Health crisis we
got a lot of people on these these heavy
antidepressants and it sends them off
the deep end and maybe he was just a
nice hippie peaceful Berkeley guy you
know just living out his best life in
the nude and then he snapped that's the
real story maybe he ate Taco Bell and
then he just went like
some raw milk maybe the Taco Bell had a
bunch of ssris in it that someone just
laced in there accidentally when they
were working for the company and then
you know that brain chemistry just got
all out of whack and then now this is
not a natural health conspiracy but I do
think if you eat nothing but fast food
your brain is probably going to be
messed up in a certain way and what what
I mean is like simply put you're
probably missing some nutrients if
you're only eating a lot of this garbage
like that Super Size Me guy he said the
reason he wanted to eat McDonald's for
for 30 days was because if they serve
breakfast lunch and dinner they clearly
want you to be eating it their response
like we don't expect someone to eat to
eat nothing but McDonald's but it's like
dude if you're selling food people are
gonna eat your food that should be the
regulatory standard it's like if you
only eat your food for X period of time
what are the impacts it shouldn't just
be the one-off time you eat it it should
be a uh a set period of time over a
month whatever it is yeah otherwise you
wouldn't should have a prescription
right if if it's not if you're not able
to have it well I guess what do they say
with alcohol just use it at your own
prescriptions are regulated it hasn't
impact you over the entire time of the
prescription it should be the same if
you're for food a month two months
whatever it is so here's what's funny he
they say in the San Francisco Chronicle
that the dude had a Blog with screeds
about the ruling class right-wing
conspiracy theories and racial slurs yo
the the the the popular stuff is left
and right that's the thing like he was
Green Party
it was funny I saw someone post I can't
remember who posted it they said that
like the Venn diagram of uh a trump
supporter and a nudist Berkeley hippie
is not a circle and I'm like it probably
overlaps right to be to be completely
like for real a bunch of anti-war
leftists became Trump supporters well
eight million uh Obama voters nine voted
for Trump I mean there was a huge Bernie
contingent uh after the primary I mean
this is a real phenomenon and like you
said it's a populism that crosses
partisan lines and uh it really just
speaks to the anti-establishment nature
of a lot of these guys he's clearly
anti-establishment if you're going to
try to assign any kind of overarching
political ideology to him but beyond
that I mean where this guy falls on a
right left Spectrum who knows I mean
they mentioned he posted Q stuff too and
that's why I'm like the dude's clearly
just crazy yeah but if you want to play
games you know in the media well he was
a green party right there you go yeah I
think when you talk about ruling class
it's really an economic issue and that
can be left or right or up or down I
suppose pose well it's really not yeah
it's not that linear Spectrum it's that
square you know the Libertarians those
like to use with the authoritarian not
authoritarian economic uh statism you
know lazy fair so if you put it on that
it makes a little more sense but he was
a hemp jewelry maker like I just no
wonder he went off he's probably blown
his mind out on psychoactives is Mike
where's Nancy so daily Mouse he had a
hit list of other politicians yeah well
I'm glad he's Behind Bars is that what's
he what's his name he's facing attempted
murder charges yeah right now was he
going to be let off he's Canadian he's
Canadian oh there you go also really
apparently anti-semitic as well
I think he's just crazy yeah and and
that's the first thing you know it's
it's funny that what's going to happen
now based on the Q stuff and the
election stuff is the left is going to
say he's a right winger right and then
when you point out he's a green party
they're going to be like no that doesn't
matter because he did this you know what
I mean what annoys me about this is that
you go to the city and you have attacks
like this on the subway weekly monthly
constantly Asian Americans Jewish
Americans whoever it is they get
attacked by lunatics like this and those
guys are out you know within a week from
bail reform or whatever and then
obviously it finally hits home to the
elites and I'm not trying to downplay it
it's obviously horrible what happened to
her husband but it just goes to show
that you know it's only becoming an
issue and there's only going to be some
serious there was a guy in New York City
that was caught on a viral video putting
an ax in front of a woman's face after
smashing up a McDonald's yes threatening
to to essentially and they interview her
with it he got out the next day and he
was on New York one he was doing
interviews he was on the media circuit
and he was like oh listen I just had a
it was hot I had a rough day and it was
like yeah this guy have been this guy
and then and then a couple days later he
got arrested again from stealing a bike
and running away after doing graffiti
and and again this guy of course is
going to have a very stiff sentence this
guy is of course going to be kept in
jail other people who commit other
crimes unregular Joe smells they just
get let go every single day because of
the George Soros appointed District
Attorneys all throughout the United
States that have been causing Havoc
everywhere and when I was talking about
banning Hammers and blunt objects we got
to understand many years according to
the FBI statistics more people have died
from hammers uh than than rifles I'm
pretty sure it's illegal to walk around
Chicago with a baseball bat well it
depends if you're coming from like a
baseball field like it depends on how
you're brandishing it right no uh my
understanding at least this is what the
cops told us they were like if we see
you with a with a baseball bat we can
arrest you for a possession of a weapon
but typically if you have a baseball bat
and a baseball together they could but
you probably won't get in trouble but
that's how that's how broken things are
so in in Illinois I'm pretty sure like
the only way weapon or in Chicago the
only weapon you can have is it used to
be this way pre the uh what was the
decision in DC was it uh Heller was it
Heller I don't know you still want to
look it up the handgun decision in 2008
it was a hell it was how to learn versus
you could only have a two foot long
rubber switch for a whacking somebody
wow yeah and and all the criminals had
guns right so you know we know how that
worked out it's just asymmetrical
Warfare you know law-abiding citizens
you know you're off on your own with
that rubber thing you just mentioned and
good luck bringing it to a gunfight dude
I don't know if you guys saw this video
out of New York where there's some
there's there's a guy there's a guy in a
hood on the subway and then another guy
is walking money with business first guy
just runs full speed and then boom body
slams him right onto the tracks and then
runs for it what happened to that guy
that got knocked on the tracks I don't
know about that guy I know that several
people have been killed yeah what would
you do I mean happened in front of you
jump down on the tracks grab the guy and
get him up onto the platform you try I
guess like you don't want to land you're
gonna make sure he's not touching the
other third right now and you can't
touch him you got locked in well there's
always delays we're blown back every
time there's a delay like that I mean
you know what happened you may not be at
that stop you may be a while away but
it's a commute either either someone did
it themselves it's a suicide or one of
these instances when I lived in New York
I used to think like okay I don't need
to work out all the time I wasn't
obsessed with being strong but I was
like I need to be strong enough so that
if someone falls on the track I can jump
down and get them up out of the track I
consciously think about where my head
would land if I was just pushed if it
would make it to the track and I just
try to give myself an extra foot or two
in case someone comes from behind but
depending on the force it doesn't really
matter they can get you on that onto the
tracks if they really push and then I'm
sure MTA will say don't go down there
it's too dangerous don't put yourself at
risk if someone falls on the track but I
I that was just through my head I'm like
God hope that guy's okay is it uh Luke
was it Japan or Singapore where they
have glass blocking it's in Japan
Singapore there was in high school when
they installed those and it's like
basically just doors that are exactly
like the train doors they open and then
they allow you to go through the door
and then the airports yeah separate
glass line just I think Japan does that
too Japan does that as well not for
crime and then suicide if you kill
yourself in Japan there's particular uh
lines and particular access roads where
there's bigger fines for the family
members of the individual that killed
themselves than other roadways that
aren't as popular so your family gets
fined like in Japan if you kill yourself
that is interesting they have seppuku
right which is like a historical a
traditional thing of like an honor
suicide or whatever and so it's
interesting that that there is an
element of some kind of high suicide in
Japan I wonder if that's just like a
cultural thing persisted so people are
more willing to do it I don't know
culture long working hours you know it's
a I feel it's a litany no families no
babies they sell more adult diapers than
baby diapers that's coming to a country
near you the population coming it's here
it's already here thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there